something that seemed Unthinkable two
months ago Carson is back in Ukrainian
hands cars driven by soldiers swarmed by
Overjoyed residents the Ukrainian flag
raised above Freedom Square once more
glory to Ukraine and glory to the heroes
they chant touching scenes as residents
rushed to hug their Heroes and such a
reversal of Fortune Russians rolled into
the city at the beginning of the war
never intending to leave the
counter-attacks so stunning Russian
troops fled leaving behind a warehouse
full of ammunition it's an important
victory for Ukraine and it's the
completely demoralizing and humiliating
for Russian troops so this is really a
turning point in the war uh in Ukraine
right now a turning point and
strategically crucial that the Russians
were forced back across the nepro river
they've also achieved significant
military objectives yes to taking back
of of Castle City and it's significant
because of the geography for Ukraine it
essentially it protects the Southeastern
Coastline it protects Nikolai if it
protects Odessa it puts far more
pressure on Crimea in the South and also
not only Crimea in the Russian forces
there but also the Russian Black Sea
Fleet it was just six weeks ago that
Russian President Vladimir Putin
celebrated the annexation of four
regions including kershan but when the
decision was made to pull troops out it
was left to a Russian general to
announce it
more than thirty thousand Russian
service Personnel weapons and Hardware
were withdrawn he said soon the winter
weather will slow the military campaigns
on both sides a top U.S general has
suggested now would be a good time for
diplomacy for Ukraine to negotiate peace
from a position of strength but
Ukraine's president has always made
clear his country will keep fighting
until all Russian troops are out
excited says you're in a volchuk we knew
this day would come our boys would
liberate us
the Russians have left much of Curson in
Ruins and residents know they could be
attacked again
but today is a good day
Eric Sorensen Global News